the xbox ecosystem is changing with
series x
it's microsoft's goal to let you play
the same games no matter which console
you own
but there are still plenty of games from
xbox's past that we want to see make a
comeback
here's what we'd love to see make a
return on series x
let's start with exclusives and a sixth
mainline gears of war is pretty much a
given
the ending of gears 5 definitely leaves
the door open for it
gears 5 will get series x enhancements
and it would be cool to see the same
fidelity in a fresh gears game
one that further expands on the improved
horde mode and the not as well received
escape mode
crackdown 3 wasn't well received either
but a new console is another chance for
the xbox favorite to return
3 was supposed to utilize the cloud for
its physics and explosive destruction
but the wrecking zone mode we got didn't
live up to the hype
since then we've seen the release of
xcloud which could be an avenue to truly
capitalize on that cloud processing
sunset overdrive was also full of
destruction but fans loved its smooth
movement and comedic moments too
since the game's 2014 launch developer
insomniac games has been acquired by
sony
and since insomniac retained the rights
to the property i guess that includes
the sunset overdrive ip
too but a multi-platform sequel isn't
impossible
that's not the only multi-platform game
we want to see come back either
dead rising started on the xbox 360 and
a return on series x
perhaps even starring frank west once
again would feel like a homecoming
microsoft is always touting the power of
the series x
so just imagine all the zombies they
could get on screen
alan wake tangled with plenty of
monsters of his own in both the original
game and its standalone follow-up
american nightmare
both of which were xbox exclusives
developer remedy was working on a sequel
but it eventually morphed into quantum
break a proper sequel or even another
stand-alone adventure would be really
exciting for fans of remedy's work
especially after the next piece of alan
wake related dlc
coming to control ryze son of rome
doesn't really have the same fan base
but the xbox one launch title
is known for being very very pretty the
series x would be the perfect place to
revive the ip and show off the new
console's power
a planned sequel was cancelled due to
developer crytek not wanting to hand
over the ip to microsoft
so the new generation would also be a
chance at a clean slate for the two
companies
the amp series isn't known for being
pretty but the third game did get really
zany with puppet cutscenes
over-the-top injuries and a generally
goofy tone
in a world without a new ssx game amped
4 is the perfect chance for the series x
to fill a snowboarding void
moving from comedy to horror series x is
also a great place for condemn to make a
comeback
the original 360 game gave players all
sorts of
person melee combat and puzzle sobbing
to enjoy and it was all rooted in
survival horror
it would fit right in with other series
x games we already know about
like the medium and scorn speaking of
first person brawling
the cult classic breakdown received
praise back on the original xbox for
having you do everything in a first
person pov
controls were specific from opening
doors to climbing ladders to of course
fighting a remaster or second breakdown
would be a great deep cut for the series
x
on a more light-hearted note it's been a
while since we've seen fusion frenzy
the party game got a sequel 13 years ago
and that was it
make a new one put it on game pass and
you've got an instant incentive to buy a
series x and play with friends online
wins
i'm so good it hurts castle crashers is
another great one to play with friends
and the game's initial launch during
summer of arcade was a seminal moment
for the xbox live marketplace
the summer of arcade promo has been gone
for some time now
but bringing back the label with a
full-on castle crashers 2 would be a
real treat for former xbox 360 gamers
jonathan blow's braid was also part of
that initial summer of arcade lineup
his next project is intended to be
broken up into multiple installments
and the series x is a great place to
kick it off braid is the game that put
blow on the map so returning to xbox
would be a natural move
let's talk about another summer of
arcade hit geometry wars 2.
we've gotten a third game since then but
a fourth on series x would be another
great way to bring back the summer of
arcade promotion
plus the power of the series x would
make the already pretty series look even
better
with ultra high resolution and frame
rate and if we are bringing back summer
of arcade
a new paygo game would be a great
addition to the lineup
it's been many years since peggle 2 and
another super chill game in the series
would feel pretty great right about now
plus it's an excuse for another
over-excited announcement
i'd say i was speechless but i have one
more thing to announce
coming this year pagle 2.
katan was another hit xbox live arcade
game and a strong piece of the 360's
online multiplayer scene
it would be a perfect game pass edition
letting subscribers play together with
their friends anywhere in the world
and it's no longer for sale on xbox at
all so the only way we're getting it
again is with a comeback on series x
you know what else should make a
comeback banjo and kazooie original
developer rare might be caught up in
everwild right now
but the banjo-kazooie ip is in
microsoft's hands and to be frank nuts
and bolts just
isn't the same game as the nintendo 64
originals a remake of those or a full-on
banjo 3e would make a great series x
edition
that's not the only platforming series
that can make a return either
we haven't seen blinks the time sweeper
since the second game in 2004
if microsoft wants to dig deep and bring
back another platform mascot on series x
links is it every sweeper is a hero now
more recently microsoft released super
lucky's tale
so a sequel to that game is another fine
option for character platforming on
series x
super lucky's tale was a big part of the
play anywhere program
and a new game would be a great tie-in
to the new push for game pass and xcloud
connectivity
on a less cutesy note original xbox
shooter black could also make a comeback
on series x
we were supposed to get a sequel but it
was scrapped bringing back the black
brand under season shooter developers
like the coalition could be a smart move
from black to blue let's talk about blue
dragon 2.
360 exclusive rpg blue dragon was the
first game built by final fantasy
creator hironobo sakaguchi's studio
mistwalker after he left square enix
it's not the only game in the series but
we never did get a mainline sequel
the xbox hasn't been known for its rpgs
but a blue dragon 2 would be a move
toward changing that
the same goes for infinite undiscovery a
one and done exclusive rpg on the 360.
it had a lot of ambitious systems like
large parties story changing decisions
and a scrap day night cycle that could
really shine with the series x's
processing power
also trying to name a sequel to
something called infinite undiscovery
would just be funny to hear
reaching farther back into rpg history
xbox was the only console where you
could play
jade empire an important bioware game
that lay the groundwork for future
series like mass effect and dragon age
honestly bioware needs a win after mass
effect andromeda and anthem
so a remake or full-on sequel to jade
empire could be a return to form on
series x
sticking with the eastern world let's
talk ninja blade before it took over the
world with its souls games from software
released ninja blade on the 360.
this action game is nothing like the
soul series with a whole bunch of
cinematic action
and quick time events that cinematic
quality would only be improved by the
power of the series x
another ninja game we'd love to see is
ninja gaiden the reboot kicked off in
the early aughts on xbox
and it capitalized on the console's
online features with in-game master
ninja tournaments
we haven't seen a game in the series
since 2012 so ninja gaiden 4 or another
reboot could again capitalize on the
xbox's online ecosystem with the series
x and game pass
i'm just trying to feed my kid please
don't come any closer
we haven't seen mary's edge in a few
years either but the two games are known
for a beautifully rendered futuristic
city
the sequel even let players build their
own point-to-point time trials
now picture this an even larger open
world city
shared by players like the ocean and sea
of thieves you could build all sorts of
challenges for other players on series x
speaking of other players kanan lynch is
all about co-op
and it's been mia since the second game
released a decade ago
a new cooperative shooter sequel would
be another great incentive if it were
put on game pass on series x
especially if non-members could join in
with friends in some sort of free trial
it's also been some time since we've
seen steel battalion with the latest
game being 2012's connect-based heavy
armor
it was not a well-received game which
means steel battalion has something to
prove in the next generation with a new
game
or reboot this list could use more of a
party vibe so let's talk viva pinata
these sim games let you customize your
own garden to attract
all types of wild pinatas as you tried
to collect every one
but we haven't seen one on xbox since
2008 at least you can revisit it with
the rare replay compilation
speaking of compilations we're due for
an orange box too
the orange box was first on xbox 360
featuring tons of great valve games like
half-life 2
team fortress 2 and of course the debut
of portal
at this point a second orange box on
series x would include
so many more hits like left 4 dead
portal 2
and perhaps even console ports of dota 2
or half-life alex
alright i'm getting hungry so let's wrap
this up with some fast food games
remember the burger king trilogy sneak
king big bump in and pocket bike racer
we need more of those in the next
generation and something tells me
wendy's or arby's would be super into it
you've always wondered who's behind
the mask the answer
is you and those are the games we'd like
to see return on xbox series x
what do you want to see make a comeback
in the next generation sound off in the
comments below and stick with gamespot
for all the best next-gen coverage
[Music]
you